okay well four people joining this live
stream we are about to talk about a
knotty problem in Wolfram language and
notebooks that we've been sort of
putting off talking about for a while um
I see that I have notes here from
January 2018 but actually this question
has a history that goes way before that
and the question is percent and the
bigger issue is when you have a notebook
and you are doing computations and use
percent you end up with a notebook where
when you come back to it later it's like
what on earth two percent mean that is
the question and then you know the
alternative is people make up variables
you know hello equals two plus two
sometimes when they're working quickly
I'm a big offender in this the variable
names they make up a kind of terrible
and in addition then there's there's
still you know state that they have to
recover in their notebook if they want
the thing to work and if they created
that in a different notebook it's just a
big mess so let's try and refresh our
memory because I had an idea my
fundamental idea was that percent should
bring up a suggestions tongue so to
speak that offers you various things
that percent might mean um but let's
let's look at um okay so so puff has
some notes here percent in time yeah so
just as background this is a document
that I put together some brainstorming
and Michael and eat I participated in
reviewing a version of this but these
are brainstorming concepts I'm not
necessarily Wed to anything here but
some stuff to talk about I think okay I
mean we also talked about you know in
the modern world every cell has a UUID
correct
yes and so in principle something that
refers to a cell can be could refer to
the UUID of that cell well and in fact
in fact it's on our roadmap and also
mentioned here but it's on our roadmap
that we are going to change the full
form of notebook object and cell object
which right now just use internal IDs
that don't that don't persist between
sessions between front end sessions
where is that where is that ID is that
in there
the it's just the first argument of cell
object and notebook object or the sorry
it's first argument of cell object of
notebook I mean I think Stephen is
asking where is the ID in the cell and
it's not oh no no we we don't show it
show it in the show so Express how do I
get the cell object four percent 207 for
example you you can do cells bracket
bracket gives you the there you go then
we also have a right-click copy a Cell
object maybe we added something and I
forgot you know we do I forgot about
that I'm certain I added it too I forgot
okay so there's the cell object is that
is a junior UUID basically well it's
it's it's an ID which is only unique for
this session right so it's a pointer
into memory or something like that yeah
yeah okay fine but so in general we
could end up with a UUID there which you
know which we can readily tell is it
resolvable or not within that notebook
yeah yeah and this is already planned
already mapped out we just have to get
it implemented so okay so so one
possibility is that percent refers to in
space in effect a particular cell object
well I don't think percent literally no
no but I mean
when I say a conceptual % object yes is
I'm imagine what it's like but what I'm
imagining is you type percent and you
get a pulldown here that shows you I can
I versions of certain previous cells in
the document like the most recent so so
to my mind it's like you know show icon
eyes um you know cells including the
most recent kernel cell you know the
cell immediately above you those are the
tumors but but by the way though I mean
presumably you don't want to actually
show you don't want to actually make it
the I can eyes cell but it might have
some massive thing you want to make an
icon eyes version of like this this you
know answer data thing on the left or
something like that well I think there
are two ways you could go and I
enumerate both as possibilities if you
read farther down one is you can have a
reference so the output to the previous
inputs you know and and then if you
really that input then you know you'll
you'll get you know the reference will
of course automatically update but the
other possibility is you might want to
do something equivalent to copy output
from above but in I can eyes form and
and I I think both are valid do we want
to present both choices you know when
you know having people try to figure out
kind of you know more choices what
exactly do I want to do but that might
be a bad thing but but both are valid
things to potentially want to do hold on
so when I'm getting up to speed here I
mean one of the things that you're
suggesting is one of the outcomes is you
know okay so the question is what is in
the notebook okay and one answer is an
ionized expression which is in other
words ie a a burnt in for all time
version of whatever you got apps
whatever yes okay
another possible assist this is the
percent bye-bye value suggestion
basically right which is right which are
you seeing that written hit somewhat
because that's a good characterization I
didn't call it percent by value but
that's an excellent name right and that
right already exists that's
shift-command oh except except that it
doesn't auto I can I sure right so that
is basically so what you're saying
that's equivalent to shift command L
adding or two eyes organization with
auto-ionization added yep yeah only if
the output actually appears in the
notebook well I was just gonna say
there's a little bit more Auto stuff
around that that we may not want to dive
into immediately but has to do with
determining whether or not that command
ship cell represents a complete
expression and I can imagine ways to
kind of factor through that but that's
maybe diving too deep for the moments
yeah and also just as a pedantic detail
I think command shift l actually copies
the line above regardless of whether was
the last thing evaluated that should not
be the case I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I thought you were saying
something else it copies the
positionally previous output cell right
so so this is which is essentially above
that's what I got confused right so this
is so this here is copies copies
positionally yeah right so there's
there's okay so wait a minute so there's
there's okay so there's two things
there's the destination of % the what
percent is making and there's where it
comes from right those are two different
different questions yes I'm the green oh
okay so what percent is
making yeah that's for for permutations
one of which we implement now and three
of which I discuss in my proposal okay
all right which we should read um um
where percent is coming from okay so
what percent is making could be a I can
eyes depression I can eyes burnt an
expression or it could be a a well
actually there's several things that
could make I mean that it could make
well it's a reference of some sorts yeah
reference to something and it could be a
positional reference it could be you
know I could imagine somehow it is in
yes okay but but now the other
possibility which which has come up in
things like data set is out of course
storage why would you want to use
percent for her out of core storage I
mean it seems like there other I mean if
nothing else to use like local object or
something like that there are a lot of
different ways of representing you that
no I understand it but if you want to
say take this thing and when this
notebook comes back to life again have
it refer to the same thing you might use
about what you mean in somewhere stored
in the dot MB file though I'm not sure
I'm not sure or it could be in the cloud
or anything it could be in any
persistence location question mark
store store the value of percent in any
persistence location I mean that may or
may not be sensible but it seems like um
well so that's that's related to
something that I wasn't prepared to
discuss but something which has been on
our back burner for a while which is
this notion of having of having assets
which are not in your notebook but which
you can reference to and typeset in the
notebook right I understand
um orbiting assets
it's arguably doper for this application
this is equivalent to I can I'd saying
it if it's going to be in the notebook
yeah unless it appears more than once
that's interesting point I don't think
that's I don't think we should worry
about that case for this I think I
intentionally read what John had had
written here okay offer to replace it
with a summary blog that survives the
session like I can eyes mm-hmm and by
the way the summary blob you know once
you make it could have an ionized
version of the expression in it yeah
yeah I imagine that as being part of the
metadata right to remind you what it is
so what you would see is something very
similar I mean you know I can eyes has
been a nice successful thing um so what
you would basically see is something
that has some has this but an enhanced
version of I can eyes um I mean I can
eyes itself good so that's another issue
is some oops the you know displaying I
can eyes expressions I mean I can eyes
itself could do better than that
in terms of displaying what that
expression is like
I mean you know we could look and the
first approximation we could just use
icon eyes this mechanism sure um
now by the way the trickiest thing
around this is just you know having a
technology which can produce a
reasonable thumbnail in a guaranteed you
know a portion of time you don't want it
to end up doing inadvertently doing like
10 seconds worth of work producing a
thumbnail right so that comes up in our
web also for cloud notebooks ok the
exact same problem and I'd like to point
out to you that well it's it's a little
different because there you're trying to
thumbnail the entire notebook as opposed
to an expression let me show you
something which I think has been
surprisingly successful I don't actually
even know how it was done um he says now
seeing something that failed why did
that one fail but look at these all
these lovely why did these fail hmm
well having having said that you know
they mostly work beautifully and I think
this is a pretty simple heuristic that's
finding these things
no comments do you know how this works
John I don't know how that thing
specifically works but but I'll just
point out that you know for example when
dealing with a notebook one of the
problems is you know you were dealing
with a physically sized thing so maybe
it captures the top I don't know you
know 600 points it is certain with mmm
but then what if you have a cell that
starts you know that starts 400 points
down and then the cells like a mile tall
and we have to have enough smarts to
realize oh we don't want to try to
bitmap or even draw that entire thing
can we just use short at some point and
then not for notebooks see short is you
can do for expressions but you can't do
it for notebooks that's why I'm saying
the notebook that
is actually a bit different from the
expression thing okay fine
all right okay but but so anyway so
we'll get some display there all right
um syntax highlight percent which is
probably no longer valid oh I see I see
you're saying you're saying a percent
that is dead how do you indicate that
yes so in the same way that we we've
done we we update the ends yeah the ins
and outs that are that are no longer
relevant we update those and we could do
the same thing with a legacy percents
anko be a good idea yeah honestly a
legacy percent is very dead I mean it
could could as well I mean it's see it's
it's not totally without controversy
because you know a percent may be
intended to be if you evaluated this
entire notebook in sequence it would be
a valid percent yes okay fair enough
okay um-hmm okay all right let's look at
this thing here percent in space okay
some input cells generate multiple
output cells oh for goodness sake what
is percentage iiiii I know you wish that
were not the case but yes I I knew you
would
I mean this is one of many reasons why
it's sort of a bad idea yeah um but but
but I think we can I think we can still
do it I mean it's a simple offset to say
you know the second output of the input
cell and of course you can still edit
the input cell to change that but what
are you proposing will it be out seven
coma two or something well I'm proposing
that the full form which this just this
made-up thing based on a name I don't
really like very much but this full form
would basically first of all it would
reference the input cell not the output
cell and second of all it would just
give you an integer offset saying the
first op with the second half with the
third operator whatever what is this
thing what is the sound so day two thing
so this is the reference this is the
anchored ref
it's it's basically saying it's it's a
proxy for the output cell generated by
that input cell okay I see so when it's
referenced it's referenced relative to
an input cell yes because what's the
point of referencing if it's reference
relative to an output cell is that
obvious I mean because you might rewrite
the outputs no that's not obvious at all
you might want both references right you
might want referenced reference the
output of a given input cell or you
might want to say reference a particular
output except that if that output if
that Patel is regenerated it will no
longer have the same UID
yeah yeah that that that's a property as
you lose your UUID when you delete and
recreate the output cell and and that's
not something that I'm gonna give up
lightly no I understand that but so what
would be the what would be the issue so
you're saying that it's pointless to
reference an output cell you might as
well if you want it it's not gonna be
stable exactly that's precisely what I'm
saying
okay so then then guarantee the input so
is stable either but what are you doing
based on shift under evaluation no I
understand but what do you do if the
input cell is deleted so in that case
this you know the typeset thing that
you're showing would would update to
indicate that you know it's reference is
no longer valid okay so if and it would
evaluate to something I don't know you
know a failure object or something I
don't know how it would evaluate but it
would visually show what it will wilt
the output the output icon the the
output blob will wilt
whatever that means yeah and I think in
that case we can provide an interface if
you want to retarget it to something
that is valid you know we slide that
interface so in other words let's delete
it up a bubble wilt okay
together with but-but-but oh by the way
here's it here's a clever thing - if you
cut and paste an input cell the first
thing that you pasted will have the same
expression UUID I see I understand so if
did I spell that right should that be a
spelling would I think it probably
should be what I'm looking up right now
I think it is I think I've seen it
before but yes it is okay all right well
that's done that in path could you send
that into spelling okay so so if the
cell is quotes moved by copy/paste by
cut and paste it has to be cuts yeah
okay not copy I see by cut paste it will
preserve its UUID yeah and that's
already true today
okay now if it's moved by copy if the
cell is copied it's the old version it's
the old copy that is the reference it's
the it's yeah it basically changes yeah
yeah it's the original that's the
reference I mean it's part of the
retargeting we could try to see if that
cell do we know if that cell was
repositioned somewhere else
well the I mean I mean we can if that's
useful information it's not clear to me
that that we need to know that it moved
okay but it but if it's useful
information yeah we can figure that out
okay all right so then we can also you
know if the cell was was moved by you
know say by a destructive operation like
by say copy paste delete but was not
otherwise modified we might be able to
hunt down its identical twin we have
ways of doing that - Oh enough with
hashes yes yeah well okay for fine I
mean hunting for a twin which which
would at least you know in the
retargeting in her face would you know
we could pop that up to the top of the
list of choices and the retargeting
interface yep
that seems like a good idea okay so okay
so let's just go down these these more
suggestions okay offer an option to
freeze percent what does that mean well
so maybe maybe it was a reference but
now you want to lock it in for some
reason right you finally got the the
output that you exactly wanted so now
you want to do D by value rather than
the by reference so yeah I mean I mean
you could you could either do this the
first time out or you could do it you
know after you've iterated the notebook
for a bit so you're saying that the
percent blob would have no what you know
in this percent blob it would have a
pulldown that says for example you know
that the the the autosuggest or whatever
would include fries this value or
something yeah well no I don't think
autosuggest I think that would be you
know some oh I don't know some button
inside the blob okay so is that
analogous to the kinds of things that
are in dataset where it says kind of you
know don't refer to an external file
store this in the notebook is that sort
of an analogous thing yes I think it is
right and it and or maybe the store now
button that you have on both datasets
and also sparked large stars sparse
arrays okay it's not exactly the same
thing but it's basically yeah right but
it might have the same design treatment
yeah okay we got a number of suggestions
on the live stream here which are which
I want to look at in a second here um I
hadn't been scrolling my my chat view so
I thought there was nothing is it
reasonable okay so the next question you
had is is it reasonable to support
roll-up
I see well yeah I mean it would be
lovely to have a rollup yeah I'm not a
hundred percent certain if roll-up is
well defined but it might be I haven't
really thought it all the way through
well I mean roll-up with multiple
percents so in other words resolved so
this is a percent by value could it have
roll-up well I mean recall that you know
the predictive interface what it does
with roll-up is it actually it actually
squashes a quote quote squashes cells
together I mean it takes say a sequence
of four cells and replaces them with a
single I know but it only does that if
those cells were created by the
predictive interface so it's exactly
exactly
no I mean here the the the obvious thing
to do was so one sense of this doesn't
make any sense at all because you're
taking that 17
and you're saying you know if I if I'm I
can izing this I'm ionizing that I don't
care where it came from
yeah the question is am i icon izing the
operation so what what you want to do
here is to icon eyes it's really a
percent by reference that is really the
interest in case of this what is
happening to those cells okay so that
this is a percent by reference where
what would happen is that it would say
basically it would say you know
reference squared plus one right it's
what you would put in there well or it
might roll it up all the way it might
literally have a two plus two quantity
squared plus one by the time it does
that why isn't it just using 17 oh
because it's a I see because because you
might be wanting to get rid of input
cells yeah I understand but what one
thing we haven't been addressing here
and the cyclization is you might want to
icon eyes I see what you're saying so
this is effectively ionization of
ionization of input as a post output
right so one one thing you might want to
do is basically say out 203 that's what
you're storing the value of out 2 or 3
I'd also want to be storing the
reevaluate a bowl in line there yeah and
and you know this is one of those things
that we're you know roll-up is a little
weird because roll-up you know take
something that actually used outputs and
reconstructs it from the constituent
inputs and you know that's a little head
scratching and maybe it's maybe people
don't think about that much in
predictive interface but here maybe it's
a little too head scratching I don't
know well look I think the main issue is
you might want something where this
thing says you're not now plus you know
whatever it is it's something when you
re-evaluated it will change possibly
because it's capturing other variables
and things like this yes yes so or it
could have a random in it or something
right so basically this says so wait a
minute so the interface is either you
are storing
okay so the burning in interphase
you know the burn in interphase could
either be either burn in the output or
burn in the most resolved version of the
input yeah this would be a good time for
me to emphasize that although I listed
you know these ideas I don't I'm not a
believer that we should take all the
ideas I want to have all the ideas out
for discussion but I'd like the
interface to be more focused on the
stuff that we think is really important
so okay hold on there's a bunch of
interesting suggestions on our live
stream here I just want to finish going
through these and then I'm gonna go
through the live stream months um okay
what to do if the output is no longer
available in the output cell doesn't
contain yeah well that's the wilting
idea yeah although we did discuss and I
forgot to mention it here but we did
discuss the possibility of if if it's
obtainable by some means you know like
for example it's not in the notebook but
it's still in the kernel session and we
could figure that out you know for
example the output cell has a store down
button that would still work if you just
pressed it well we could kind of
automate the pressing of it yeah I
understand what happens if the output we
referenced has dynamics and here I think
Michael was concerned about how we
thumbnail things
then we punt on the thumbnail if we have
to yeah one of the one of the things
which Michael seemed to be arguing for
it's he should speak for himself but it
seemed to be arguing for was maybe like
another input form variance you know
something that types that's graphics but
not dynamics I wasn't quite sure it's
just a scenario that I could see okay
right you mean uh um oh I see okay right
hmm like multiple ages to prime examples
that might depend on some definitions at
all changing indeed but so what are you
proposing you're proposing no I don't
have proposed it was just once think
that we should keep in mind for this
don't do it okay okay we got a bunch of
comments here from Steve on the live
stream commenting that an excel we can
name cells and named ranges could we
name cells and a contiguous range of
cells familiar with the Excel feature I
hadn't thought about it for for the
notebook front end the I mean the
principal issue is the issue of
stability in regards to generated cells
which you know of course I'm trying to
solve well let me give you an example of
a bizarre thing that one might want and
I've definitely wanted this is a cell
sequence to list so in other words given
a sequence of cells can you select a
sequence of cells that's kind of weird
can you can you select can you select a
cell you select a sequence of in out
cells
and harvest the outsells into a list so
it's like a notebook import inside the
notebook yeah
I'm not I'm not sure how valuable that
is but it's it so so the wait I mean
programmatically the way you would do
that right now is you could apply a cell
tag to all of the input cells you care
about the cell tags will auto copy from
input cell to output cell so you know so
the output cells will get that cell tag
and then you can use notebook import
selecting on a cell tag yeah that's kind
of complicated I mean if we think this
is a useful operation and actually I
have to say I would have used it a bunch
of times I mean if I get this is kind of
a I hadn't really thought about it in
this way but I select a bunch of stuff
in the notebook I right-click I get
something which allows me to essentially
do an in notebook notebook import all
right anyway that that's the best I can
do to make sense of that um okay mohamed
is commenting since percent consumers
memory it might be useful to know how
much memory all of the stuff is
consuming yeah I mean that was more of
an issue back and do you realize by the
way we almost have a virtual machine
that will allow us to run version 1.2
that may seem like a non sequitur but
back in those days right we used to have
a memory monitor right in the notebook
to make sure you weren't using too much
memory I I'm you know maybe I'm spoiled
by having a mishima but a terabyte of
memory or something
um the UM but it seems to be less of a
problem these days so as far as the
memory consumed by the notebook that is
something that we can get our hands on
today although a little trouble getting
to work on my windows development front
end here but it it's it's it's
information that's available
in the notebook history dialogue yeah I
know I don't think anybody uses it but
it is there
and I you know for example one thing
that I often want to know is I've got
this notebook can I send it in email and
usually I experimentally just try and
put it in my email and it complains that
it's too big but I also do know that I
can go look in the notebook history but
it's certainly a nuisance now of course
the interesting thing about the notebook
history is that it's you know the
numbers there they have a relationship
obviously but it's not the same you know
then that is you know RAM usage that is
not on disk usage why does it pink why
did that pink because as you say it's
not a feature that gets used all the
time so there are are bugs but also the
kind of more important thing which I'm
seeing and we should fix this is yes
that's off the bottom of the screen and
I can't get it to resize or scroll on my
system either that's that's just it's a
little embarrassing we should just fix
that I think it's easy to fix
okay parson can you uh can you file this
for Larry I think it should be pretty
straightforward for to fix yeah and also
I don't know what's causing the pinking
but but somehow it's transiently
thinking yeah that may be harder to fix
but the cell statistics not being able
to be viewable that's that's easy okay
all right let's keep going here so so
we're saying
I mean in terms of of memory usage it
could be the case that we want to notify
if you're going to icon eyes well when
do you care I'm not quite sure when to
notify you about memory usage well I
mean you know we don't need to throw
something you know throw up a dialogue
or a notice or something like that you
know we can just have you know it can be
just something like you know you know
like like a little bar or or whatever
you know that gets you know bigger or
redder or something as as it consumes
more mem
mmm I don't know it depends on how much
memory is available I think that's a
honestly I think that's the 30 year
throwback and I'm I'm well okay anyway I
um I think well I mean of course the
thing which does I can ice already do
this I mean we can certainly have it in
the metadata oh it's that I mean it says
right there it says bite count yeah yeah
okay so maybe that's the answer to the
question um okay
Nexus point brian says it'd be nice to
be able to select a range of cells and
freeze them with respect to percent oh I
see what you're saying so in other words
take a range of cells which have
percents in them that's a good idea and
fix all the presents right in other
words instead of yeah that's a good idea
so in other words this would be a
percent minute you know bulk percent
manipulation yeah um so the right-click
menu probably in right click do do the
same operation on all percents in a
range AG icon ization so in other words
what that would be is just like we can
say icon eyes this expression in the
right-click menu will be able to say I
can eyes okay so yeah right on all
percents in the range good idea
it's yes wsh is asking can we have in
boxes as well as in and in string that's
an interesting idea why do we not have
that why didn't we have that 20 years
ago so in string will support boxes
you don't remember if I put that in 12 1
1 or if it's only in 12 2 but now I'm
glad that I noticed this bug and
actually bothered to fix it because at
least one user out there has apparently
noticed what is the what is the bug the
bug is that they that in string was just
completely ignoring standard forums if I
do this for example then you're saying
if I then say in string percent 2 1 4 I
mean in string 2 1 4 oh well here you
bet you you're on a 12-2 presumably oh
no I was thinking of no I was confusing
echo and in string and no so yeah so
interesting supports boxes and has for
some number of years yeah like 20 right
ok then I'm not okay look so so it's a
weird name right weird name that's not
right but it isn't a I mean arguably we
should we should have a different name
there because that is super confusing
actually that out to 1/5 is a string oh
that's scary which is probably not what
you would want so it's so wow just wow
probably because there's some
requirement in the kernel that in string
has to be a string okay so that's crazy
so in boxes would in fact make sense
well or there could just be a single
thing that gives you the source of the
end whether it's a string or boxes
you're not going to have two different
sources for the same input so you're
saying in source or an example or some
better name but guess ok give whatever
form of sauce was fro ok um ok right
well if we actually I mean I would want
to think some more about this but if we
had an in source I'd probably want to
deprecate in string yes we wouldn't take
it away but it would be silly to have
these two that are so similar and no no
I agree I think it's silly I think in
string is kind of look in string is
relevant for command-line interfaces
quite relevant there where it really is
just strings mm-hmm I wouldn't I I'm not
sure but if we have a good name then you
know that name will work and we just
like like he says no III don't think I
think I think we need the in string for
the command line interface case even
when sometimes it has to do crazy stuff
like this because it really does need to
be a string and lots of crazy things
will break if it isn't
I'm not suggesting changing in string
I'm suggesting that if we add an in
source which is in string when you're in
a standalone kernel and boxes when
you're in dollar notebooks that it you
know that's really the only one you need
and in string will be sort of deprecated
ie that we that we obsolete it in the
documentation not that we take yes cross
that bridge later I'm not sure I
necessarily agree okay
now the suggestion um from our live
streaming suggestion about using at
equals percent add equals so number I
don't think we need that because we
already have percent cell number um oh
that's a reset mechanism yeah it's
complicated
um okay a suggestion that n minus 1
comma hold gets the unevaluated
expression don't we have a mechanism for
that oh we don't have a mechanism for
that right now do we have a mechanism so
this is okay so this is some enhanced in
handling right the mechanism for that is
in you know number slash down values of
in oh goodness sake that's horrifying
yeah it's the language I mean I don't
think it's that horrifying but it's not
super convenient that's a decent idea
it's a decent idea I don't see any
reason why that wouldn't be sensible
unless we're trying to use these sub
cases of unless I mean so then we've
also got enhanced out references which I
don't understand at all where what
happens okay let me know wait a second
if I have a thing it's absolutely
horrifying thing where I'm doing this I
hate this okay so those get to different
out numbers that's right so percent is
6% is 8 and 2 n 2 different in numbers
is
well you just don't see it in the
interface oh really
yeah okay all right so there's no reason
to to use some okay so there's no reason
to use the second argument about okay
let's keep going here um so I try maybe
you should be able to see in the
interface I mean maybe I think that
would help me it would help me a lot it
would help me a lot of it broke it into
separate cells like I don't really see
why nobody actually uses this feature
would hate that you break it in separate
cells would would have people with
pitchforks at my door they're not going
to get your door they're gonna be a mine
but but but I I think considering the
possibility of mate you know having a
multi label there that lines alright
because I had no idea that there was a
set with separate in line there yeah
that would really help me to understand
that it did two evaluations and which
part of that thing produced which output
it would take a bit of effort for me to
figure out how to do that well but it's
but it seems like a decent idea all
right okay
let us record that path you you are
noting all these things right yes I am
um okay Ethan is bemoaning the fact that
the predictive interface is not
customizable Chris Carlson is here Chris
can you comment on that I just don't
know I mean you know syntax coloring is
also only a little bit customizable
although we hope it will become more so
yeah this has come up in the past there
are lots of complexities in the way the
predictive interface works and trying to
simplify that to something that users
can deal with this the issue complexity
because of things like timing issues and
so on so there's all sorts of stuff all
sorts of things yeah name three well the
timing issue is certainly one there I
mean there have been
where you know the front end freezes
it's reported to me and then I look into
it and know it's actually because you
know the predictive interface took you
know 10 or 20 seconds to figure out it's
stuff the particular vice has semantic
types it does this typing thing based on
the types it has rules that decide which
rules fire rights it's involved it's
quite complicated no I know it's
complicated yeah I mean that that is the
major issue that's why we have not yet
made it available to users I mean maybe
there is some simplified version that we
could do it doesn't give you all the
flexibility ok so so the comment that
from the live stream yesterday we talked
about these customizable themes for
evaluation and display and why can't the
suggestions bar be part of that that's a
reasonable idea that is a reasonable
idea I mean that was that was the I mean
yesterday that was in the context of
being able to wrap this elementary
evaluate thing around to get for
elementary math purposes but I don't
know what can you do with a style sheet
in with respect to the suggestions bar
does it have a lot of control there all
of the fonts are controllable via the
style sheet but the backgrounds and such
are not but what about the actual
functionality of the suggestions bar
so in principle it's possible to control
the actual functionality in practice
there are no such controls I'm aware of
today that's okay that's my
understanding too so I mean the question
is what we you know putting more
investments into the suggestions bar and
having it be I mean that is the obvious
place to control it is from the style
sheet in that in with a theme type
mechanism
and because we could imagine in the in
the notebook toolbar having some kind of
theme for the you know having the idea
that came up yesterday was themes for
you know evaluation themes displayed in
the notebook toolbar so for example the
elementary math evaluation theme and we
could imagine putting into the
evaluation themes things about the
suggestions bar too so you know I wasn't
there yesterday so I don't know exactly
what was discussed in general I will say
that you know we have been thinking
about themes a lot but there's and
there's kind of you know some proto
themes stuff that just a little bit that
lives in the default style sheet right
now and you see bits and pieces of it
poking out through presenter tools but
but there's some there's some
foundations that need to be firmed up
before you know we can really go whole
hog on themes I think okay sound oh and
live stream is commenting that he would
like some mechanism to make sure that
huge expressions don't get stored in out
dollar max history size or some such
other thing that's very similar to the
what what do we have for dataset we have
a mechanism there for what what is
automatically stored dollar notebook
inline storage limit so maybe we should
use that for maybe that should also
apply to percent is there any good
reason it doesn't
I guess it's not notebook in LA it's not
notebook inline storage it's it's
basically I mean I mean the current
percent doesn't take a penny right it
takes up one you know one characters
worth of storage right in a notebook but
the question is whether you're storing
whether that outline well well so in the
in the cases where percent is
effectively and I can eyes then you know
okay well well no no it does make yeah I
mean that's the case where it makes the
difference but the I mean we could
produce an object I suppose that works
this session and doesn't work in future
sessions and then telegraph that you
know somehow through the user interface
no I think the point being made is when
do you store out 17 when do you even
bother to store it if out 17 is 100
megabytes in size yeah and you know
let's say that what I had done was I'd
said you know well I see the point is
that if I say u equals 100 megabyte
expression right semicolon yeah okay
well actually I don't understand why
you'd ever do this because by the time
you can't see it and you didn't set a
variable if you said a variable to it
you're storing it anyway oh I see I see
what could happen yes yes yes yes yes
look look this is the case this is the
bad case you do this and that gets an
outline and that gets an outline and so
you've actually stored that expression
twice even though you thought you were
only storing at once because it was only
in the you see what I'm saying
no storing it we're in down values about
yeah right it's being stored in the down
values about no it's not the the down
values of that will be or no I guess
that will have it yes yeah right that's
the bad case and and it's not Auto
shared I mean look oh my it does matter
if it's Auto shared
if it's two references to the one bad no
but it's not it's not I'm imagining this
is look here I say equals random integer
you know 10 comma 10 10 million okay 10
comma million then I do the same thing
again well yes objects yeah right so I
mean I don't understand what the the
okay so here's my point is my point is
the byte count of % 2 2 2 right is is
there and so is the bike counter % 2 2 3
but the point being made by sander is he
says look I just
I'm never gonna refer to % 2 2 2 don't
store it for me
well then set history length to 0 no but
but but he doesn't want to do that he
says he only wants to do that
he wants his history when he can have it
but if he's generating you know gigabyte
expressions he'll say look I'm just not
going to worry about those do anything
well I mean one could imagine dollar
history storage limits
yes that's what that's what's being
suggested here max history size was the
I mean max um well the the default
should certainly be infinity if we
introduced course of course of course
but but I I think that's a perfectly
reasonable thing to ask for is something
which in a case like this because I'm
sure I've had sessions where I basically
did this and I didn't really think about
it and the thing was just you know using
hundreds of gigabytes of memory in the
end mm-hmm that's why you have a
terabyte of RAM on your machine yes
wondering if this is really true it
might be half a terabyte I'm not sure
they okay so now I'm not impressed
anymore um okay let's see um comment
total the megabytes rather than a number
of history entries I see what you're
saying I suit you're saying so I see so
so one suggestion here
is limit we did talk about this at one
point limit not history length but
history storage size yeah and of course
there's no out it's like a cash you know
yeah and of course there are two ways
you could do that you could you know you
could do it sequentially or you could
limit the size of any one thing that
goes in history yes that's the point
right
the toy that that's the and I think the
better thing to do is limit the size of
any one things I think the other thing
is too complicated I mean otherwise you
fill up your your history storage and
you've got a tiny little thing and it
says oh sorry you're full yeah you know
what what to throw out of the cache yeah
III have to think about this in in the
case of multiple on do because you know
it's you may have one thing that takes
you know a hundred megabytes done do
well I can't take it out of sequence so
they're gonna watch everything else out
but yeah yeah I agree this is a
different sort of scenario and that
makes sense right and also I mean I
would worry about you know right now you
know recording the history is super
simple and super fast you just record it
and if we limit one sighs okay fine you
add one test okay we see what the limit
is now if it's you know by the total
size of the history no so I don't think
it's a good idea I hope by the by the
added object so I just bite count on the
object I seen that byte count is almost
always really fast yes yes and if we
might want to call it max history item
size just to be clear but admit I agree
that makes sense um okay suggestion from
Elaine here highlight cells in use so I
suspect that is that has to do with this
thing about when you mouse over when you
hover over a cell lighting
somehow which is a thing that we have
coming right yes although another
variant of this which I discussed or I
intended to discuss yes I did is that if
you have a an anchored percent mousing
over the percent object would highlight
the thing that it references to if it's
on screen if it's not on screen it can
bring up the tool okay that two issues
that okay so this is highlighting of
referenced cells so they're two things
number one would be when you hover over
a percent indicate which cell it refers
to yeah and then the other is you know
it's it's a slam-dunk to have a
hyperlink in there you know if it's off
screen that I can take you to that cell
I see I see I see
or a hyperlink to jump to it okay so
there's a different thing which is if
you are if you are the the cell to which
something is anchored so indicate if you
are a cell that is acting as an anchor
how do you indicate that well I would on
the cell bracket and we're working on
how to generalize those cell bracket
widgets into a tray okay but so I mean
you know add an a you know an icon in
the cell bracket probably yeah and it
might also be the case that okay so now
the next question is do you want any
kind of warning if you're going to
delete that cell
well there are modes of deletion where
you don't want the warning but you could
wiggle your way through it
you don't want the warning when you've
read it right except of course you could
re-evaluate and then quit the kernel
before the evaluation finishes the Oh
actually but in that case it probably
would still be there because I guess the
we don't actually delete the old cell
until new inputs start coming through
okay but the question is warning on
deletion it will be nice if there was a
soft warning that did not in any way
require sort of click through or
anything like that the problem is by the
time you know if you say well actually I
didn't mean to do it I guess you can
always do undo yeah why not you know you
can't always do undo right so it might
as well just be a a notifier and then
you know reverse it by doing undo yeah
that does seem like a useful thing to
put up a little notify just saying this
was anchored you know this cell was used
as an anchor because it'll it'll be too
late if you've done twenty-five other
things you'll be it'll be at least way
confusing err okay um let's see total
history there's a bunch of comments
about little history sides that we've
we've from okay there's a request that I
evaluate memory available let's see what
it does now I'm going to find out
whether whether in fact I'm talking
complete nonsense or not what does that
even mean that's nothing that's just
fifty gigabytes what do I think sigh I
don't have more memory than that I don't
know how memory available actually works
I don't know I know when it goes into
swap space and things okay that was a
really lame what is this doing with this
weird thing with words did you see that
weird selection no not quite okay um
that was on the an exciting um
okay James here um oh that's interesting
so James suggests like to be able to
have a network tree of the cells with
the various in outs and be able to
manipulate it that's an amusing idea I
mean basically being able to make
computable the percent you know making
the percent knitting computable so well
I mean the question is what does he mean
by network and one possibility is I mean
you know we are keeping possibly what
he's looking for
internally for the predictive interface
I mean we have to be able to indicate
you know the relationships between you
know input and output cells for things
like roll-up and such and so we have
it's not externally exposed well it is
been done a documented way but you know
I mean the the front-end produces this
information and then lose code consume
the information for implementing things
like roll-up
okay so wait a minute there's a there's
a Ethan is suggesting as a killer
feature smarter roll up into a
functional module creates named
variables from intermediate percents
yeah one problem is what on earth should
the names be we have looked at at
various times sort of the machine
learning approach to making names for
things I think it's super hard it's like
it's like making up a product name or
making up a word in a language like what
should you call that thing the easier
version of that which I would love to do
but I don't really know what a good
interface for it is is I already have a
name in the code right there but it's a
global right now and I want to turn it
into into a module variable I see what
you're saying so wait a minute so okay
so auto auto
module II so so what you're saying is um
what you're saying is I say you you
equals five and then I say you you
squared etc etc and what I want to get
out of this is something like with you
you equals 55 you you squared well I
mean that seems like a very that is a
rollup
I mean okay so hold on I mean think
about it when you when you're in even
simpler case is you're writing say a
function it already has a module in it
and you realize you need to add a new
variable well what do you have to do you
have to go beyond and click in the
module and add it there and then click
back where you were and keep typing or
you have to you know kind of keep track
of all the things that you I feel I see
what you're saying I see so what you're
suggesting is a right click for example
so if I go through here blah blah blah
blah blah plus Z plus whatever
I bet Christopher has an opinion about
this the that you could go in the right
click here and put that as a module
variable in the nearest enclosing module
yeah I I don't know if right click is
the right interface but yes that's the
concepts why isn't right click right
interface or a copy oh it could be as an
auto suggest well
the I mean for one thing I I mean the
the two alternatives which I would
suggest one is that I might want to do
something while I'm typing you know so
you know I don't even remove my hands
from the keyboard that's one possibility
or the other possibility is that I might
want to look at it from the okay let's
look at that module list of variables
can I click on something there and then
have it show me anything internal to the
module that I might want to add because
they're my variable fine fine fine
possibly an autosuggest either at the
site of the variable or at the site of
the or at the or inside there or at the
site of the variable list and the scope
and construct yeah another sort of
extension of this is also just the if
you have an existing piece of code and
you just want to rot matte wrap module
around it and then it maybe autosuggest
filling in all basically the blue
symbols
that's good any module that's a good
idea
yeah I mean those two features can work
in tandem the one can be gem and is a
superset of the other right yeah yeah
given naked code I mean there's some
there's some so there's some like
heuristics you need though because for
instance right like like you don't know
if there's some symbol that's defined on
a like if the symbol is defined at the
time that you're writing module around
it yes probably it probably local did or
a global capture it's probably capturing
a global variable right in other words
if T is already actually has a value
right right so I mean it that one
heuristic might be that if I have some
piece of code and I'm wrapping module
around it that you automatically suggest
to localize all the variables that are
not currently defined globally but for
example if I ran that code before and I
realized oh whoops I just made a bunch
of global variables laughing rapid
audience right then then it won't
suggest anything so I mean the other
arguments just to do all the variables
that are defined like everything that's
on the left-hand side of set and well I
mean I mean I think I I think I would
say
you know just begin by wrapping module
of empty lists around it and then throw
up the interface for the empty list and
just let the user choose no but I've got
a but I think well Christopher is saying
is a better idea to lexically look you
know um you know lexically look in the
scoped code for things that are on the
left hand for Forel values and suggest
those and suggest localizing rows sure
that seems like a pretty straightforward
heuristic and by the way I think that
heuristic is probably safer than the one
that that only looks at L values that
are blue right undefined opposed because
because I think that's rare that you
actually do that intentionally you do it
occasionally they're not often right
that's a good idea um
should that be fed to the code
assistance people or is that something
that would be well it's a good question
I mean you know it's the kind of
transformation that they would like to
do but they're they're not yet in the
business of building these kinds of
interfaces right that is really a useful
feature I have to say there that that
would be very useful I would have used
the Sicilian times um can we just look
at this auto roll up for a second and
whether that's interesting as well so
this would be a thing where you would
select a range of cells so this is
basically a rollup from a range of cells
I mean that does seem reasonable and if
it uses percent you could could you
invent a variable name what would you do
so in other words in this case it's
clear what the what the rolled up
expression should be I mean you could do
some like unique of n where n is the
number like the out number line number
well except that you have to base it on
the alphanumeric an alphabetic yeah you
could have some right you could start
with a dollar right you could have
dollar and
I would I would think it'd be better to
have a unicode character I mean this is
this would be totally weird but could
you not have a localized version of out
of n are you right like if you right out
of n yeah I'm just I'm just saying that
centralized out right so you're saying
but no but you'd have to localize the
whole of out no we use block or
something and localize just the down
bout just out of n for the ends you care
about I now be kind of weird but does
this block do that why not sure it would
look like it's all about sure yeah
that's what I thought
right oh and then then um okay that's
one bizarre idea another bizarre idea
okay for the percent case four percent
roll up there's this are you not used
module though by the way I mean I yeah
you could probably localize just the
things you care about for you mean this
I suspect you would want to use I assume
you is it possible to I've never tried
this with module is it possible to
localize only particular down values I
think in mine out of lots no no I call
symbol yeah its lexical um the okay so
here four percent I mean that the the of
the biggest hack would be a Unicode
character that looks like percent no
well that would be too horrific I mean
especially when people copy you know you
copy the code out until you an email or
something or who knows what and then the
percent turns into some backslash
bracket secret percent or something or
worse copies into a normal person so
when you paste it back in it defend
isn't work well maybe there's a
character that that would be preserved
maybe we should look at the Unicode
maybe there's some strange Korean
character look at the you know this
almost looks like one of these angle
things no indeed
like that it's like that you know
there's this the green question mark
right which looks like a semicolon and
then all the compilers give my errors
they say don't use a Greek semicolon or
a Greek question mark right I mean this
is like what you're saying this is an
intentional Greek question mark yes
well fair enough that might not be the
right way to but maybe there is a
Unicode character that would make sense
I mean just because we just needs to
base it on something that is but but
look I mean the roll up here would be I
mean this would this would certainly be
a nice thing to be able to get something
where the code where it's Auto creating
kind of a a transportable piece of code
alright let's let's roll up this
discussion I think we made I mean I
think they're a bunch of pretty
uncontroversial things here that are
super interesting that have to do with
you know as soon as you type percent it
has an auto suggest that asks you which
version of percent you want and there
probably has to be a keyboard way of
getting that that does not require going
into the autocomplete er so the sort of
a question of whether we want some kind
of well maybe we just want a keyboard
shortcut yeah I mean maybe we want I can
eyes to have a keyboard short as I can
eyes have a keyboard shortcut
[Music]
yes it's ctrl command quote why doesn't
it say that yeah why does it not give
keyboard shortcuts in the right-click
menu because right-click menus don't
have keyboard shortcuts why because
that's the standard yeah it is it's not
not every app does it that way but more
apps do it that way than not well maybe
that's just some Apple user interface
guideline that somebody forgot but it's
also the case see I never believed in
having more than one button on a mouse
yeah well well it's it's also the case
that I have a I mean the only way to
populate it right now is to manually
label those things and I have a
concern about you know those labels
getting out of sync if shortcut changes
which means no because that's a build as
you but you know which means now we have
to write code to have it figure out what
it is and populate that label and that's
yeah all right so listen going forward
here so it's that stuff to implement
yeah I think there is well so the I mean
it you know I would like to tighten up
the interface I mean you know we haven't
made and we're not going to do so today
obviously but you know we haven't made
hard decisions about you know how do we
not prevent it presents for choices to
the user or whatever they take percents
I really don't want to present for
choices to you know I I agree and I
think that these things here probably
should be a keyboard should there should
at least be a keyboard shortcut you type
percent and then you type something that
is you know some keyboard shortcut that
you know type percent command V as well
that's not gonna work but you know
speaking of which one other possibility
that's the toward the bottom of the
notebook is we could have customized
keyboard keyboard alias around percents
I know I'm not so keen on that that's a
big nuisance and the Escape key is
escaping from many keyboards I mean like
you mean it's a hard key now yes even
when it has that that tongue soft
whatever bar touch by yes yes the way
the way that we use the Escape key is a
little strange but the usage of the
Escape key is just so universal in so
many applications that yeah it was it
was a problem for them so
right I mean I always find it a bit
inconvenient to type the escape but I
agree that we could have mmm I don't
know I I don't know I would prefer to
see a command key well so so I mean the
escape key thing is one way in which it
helps is it's an escape hatch if you
want to do something that is possible
but not on the happy path right
I agree but look I've got one suggestion
okay which is which is generalized
command L okay so my concept would be
one of the generalizations is pull down
an icon eyes diversion right so in other
words right now if I do command L you
know I'm gonna get or whatever let me do
a better one
um okay so now I do command well if I do
command L I get that if I do come on why
not
let me get with a modifier option
command L for example brings brings in a
an ionized version of that for example
or perhaps I mean it's gonna get a
little weird but for this right or
alternatively you know bringing in the
ionized version might be the default and
I mean you know it's easy to I can I
you're saying come on shift L could
bring in the ionized version but no no
no no no we don't want to do that
[Music]
because ultimately we'd like to support
command L cycling and command shift L is
the obvious inverse of command L right
okay so wait a minute wait a minute wait
first thing is command L cycling which
is clearly a great idea definitely to be
implemented definitely do okay so that
means come on shift L then becomes the
back cycler exactly so then we need a
new thing so so I would claim them that
the the correct way to do it is okay so
so for for input cells command L cycling
and then c'mon
chef del to go backwards so then we're
going to steal command shift oh yes but
I think that won't be a tragedy because
I think that the copy output from above
is used I mean in comparison to copy
input from above I think kappa from
above is at least 10 times more popular
if not a hundred times more popular
hundred times more popular for me okay
so I've got a suggestion okay but but
but you know we can find another
shortcut for it it's what we needed the
shortcut but the idea would be that
instead of using percent and getting the
autosuggest
that brings you the icon eyes expression
have a command the new command shift
I'll bring down the output expression as
icon eyes yeah yeah I actually really
rather liked that idea I mean because I
you know the times when I use I mean
clearly you can uh nikon eyes it but
that that would be maybe with a modifier
it's uh nikon eyes but to bring it down
I can eyes by default that would give us
that would then you know then you know
sort of it's it's a discovery interface
to have percent have an auto suggests
but this is the you know for the more
experienced user this is probably what
they would do yeah
we have one comment from Esther
realizations no code assistant features
accept order completion well actually
there's a big group working on code
assistance and maybe we'll do a live
stream and talk about what they've been
doing it's pretty elaborate stuff um and
oh my gosh okay so sander is is enhance
here are offering suggestions for for
what the what the base what that what
that Unicode non percent percent might
be but but then he says but don't do
that Unicode FF 0-5 right okay we'll
just we'll just record that as a as a
bad idea
up here um okay well great um alright we
should wrap this up and thank you
everybody here and thank you to people
on the livestream people might be
interested at the top of the next hour I
am doing a completely different
livestream about the one month update on
the state of the physics project but now
I need to go get some lunch
thanks ok see you guys thanks a lot okay
bye bye